Sweden is a small very open economy we
have about nine million inhabitants and
we have a tradition of very open borders
sharing world trade with others and
pursuing very open trade policies we
members of the European Union and we use
our membership to promote open borders
and free trade where sometimes there are
strong protectionist pressures also in
the European Union we have been able to
cope with globalization in spite of our
open borders or perhaps because of it
because we have policies that are
designed to make change easier to
promote flexibility and that means that
we have been able to combine the past
decades rapid explosion of international
trade with strong employment rising real
wages and growing surpluses on the
current account
see two ways one is it was gradually
developed since the early 30s when
Keynesianism was adopted in my country
even before keynes published his general
theory the Finance Minister and the top
economists in Stockholm school economy
at all that lolene dog commercial and a
few others were highly involved in the
international economic policy debate and
they applied Keynesianism
before he published general theory and
then gradually that was expanded through
social benefits and all kinds of things
but you can also trace the roots further
there is a very strong tradition in
Sweden or the Solidarity of individuals
not being left alone of a priority given
to taking care of each other if you if
you wish and that meant that those
policies were well embedded in
temperament and culture traditions and
we built upon something that was
normally natural in the Swedish
sentiment it was not something alien
that was planted into the country so I
think that is part of the explanation
why parties that advocated more
american-style policies never succeeded
in getting any votes getting many votes
in my country and now when we had a
change of government two years ago on a
platform that actually meant lower taxes
lower benefits a retreat in in
government ambitions that could only be
elected by using a vocabulary and a
rhetoric that had the opposite element
saying this is a way to improve the
public sector this is a way to expand
this is a way to produce more security
and more jobs it was not a way to use
the American model as as